what a great week this is gonna be for
America they are freaking the [ __ ] out
Roger Stone is already calling the
videotape of the documentary footage
deep fake video
they they're in big trouble whatever is
on this video whatever the hell the
January 6 select committee is going to
show us tomorrow and we've already seen
a cue up of this from Don Lemon on CNN
where they aired some of the footage
that is possibly going to be shown
tomorrow
it's gonna be [ __ ] absolutely
groundbreaking folks
and the reason why you know this is
because Ryder stone is already out on
social media on his I don't know Trader
Social account whatever the hell this
wherever the hell he posted
it's already saying this is a deep fake
he's saying it's not real don't believe
your eyes
they're in big trouble
huge trouble here and the reason why is
because it's all premeditated of course
we know this
we know they premeditated this they were
saying it from microphones back then
even the Cheeto dust mobster but in
private they were giving the plans
in private conversations in front of a
[ __ ] documentary camera
and of course it's it's
classic Roger Stone
where he's all hopped up on something it
seems
and he's absolutely gritting his teeth
I'm surprised he has teeth left how many
how many veneers you think this guy is
bought
because he's ground them down to Nubs as
much as he grits his teeth and Jacks his
jaw
these people knew he was gonna lose
they knew he was going to lose
they knew they had to cheat to win they
understood that
there was no question the only way that
Donald Trump was going to win the
election was to steal it just like he
did the first time in 2016.
that's how they know
whether you [ __ ] you think's in those
documents that They seized
that he stole from us
it's Intelligence on him
I have no doubt in my mind now
no doubt in my mind
that Donald Trump colluded with Russia
to try to steal our democracy for a
tower in Russia
no doubt in my mind
and history will tell us
because now the government has backed
their documents
we have our documents back most of them
they confirmed this morning that yes
there are empty folders yes he did put
ketchup and eat some probably more than
likely he destroyed or sold something
where the hell they go
you're telling me dude just stole empty
classified document folders just stole
them
I mean as as trophies are to stick in a
box in his office or scatter on the
floor or stick in his desk
look folks there are high crimes
committed here
Espionage borderlining on treason I mean
when you see this video
of Roger Stone absolutely Jack jawed
hype topped up on something and he's
ready to steal the election he's saying
it out loud
and this is not in some sort of [ __ ]
weird situation where
he is not connected to the president
United States this guy talks to the
president
or did talk to the president at the time
talks to the Cheeto dust mobster as of
today
when you see this footage
he was being his sentence was being
commuted
to make sure he did not go to prison
for the president of the United States
at the time
who is an unindicted co-conspirator
in the conviction of Ryder Stone
all teeing up as tomorrow as we watch
the January 6 elect committee gonna
absolutely burn down Roger Stone's house
here on live television we're going to
cover it an hour before and an hour
after
our coverage starts at noon Eastern
tomorrow
at our regular time here on the Tony
Michaels podcast
but also you have Stuart Rhodes going to
trial which they did their damnedest
they did their damnedest to stop
you don't think they understand the the
what is going to happen if Stewart
Rhodes
the evidence gets out in the public
which it will be because it'll be shown
in open court
that Americans aren't going to connect
the dots here the only challenge we have
is for people to open their [ __ ] ears
and their eyeballs that's it
stop paying attention to football for
two [ __ ] seconds and pay attention to
your democracy which delivers you those
great Monday nights Thursday nights
Saturdays and Sundays
that you get to enjoy with your football
your democracy delivers that dummies
you think you'd have the football teams
in the structure of football
you think you'd have broadcast
television you think you think you would
have internet just go go ask those women
in Iran who are challenging the regime
go ask them about internet
and a tyrannical fascist government
shutting down your [ __ ] internet
because you want to have a voice and
Liberty
and have a choice for your Liberty go
ask them
boy this next 40 days
is going to be some of the most
important days that we've had
in over a century in this country
in the 1930s and the 1940s
fascism was on the rise in the world
but the majority of this country
knew that it was [ __ ] dangerous
and knew that it meant
democracies would topple all over the
world
they knew that
they need a threat of fascism
but it wasn't here it wasn't trying to
take over our government it was just
trying to convince people and Gaslight
people that oh what's happening Germany
isn't a big deal
the Nazis not so not so great but not so
bad either
that was the 1940s 1930s and 1940s here
under the America first party
don't thin veil it at all
but we're under threat
and we're about to see the threat that
we are under
they were going to use any means
necessary to take away your vote to take
away your way of life
that was their [ __ ] goal the entire
plan the entire scheme was to make sure
that Trump and his criminal allies
would never see the inside of a prison
cell that's what they're terrified of
their scared little
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] that's what they are
just like Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh
and the rest of them Tucker Carlson Sean
handy a bunch a goddamn [ __ ]
that can't that don't want to be held to
account for their nonsense and their
crimes
and they think they're above it all
and they blame leftists for being
elitist and entitled get the [ __ ] out of
here with that nonsense
no one more entitled than Trump his
children and his [ __ ] band of
miscreants
no one more entitled and anyone anyone
who [ __ ] supports him or votes for
him is in the same goddamn trees in his
category as far as I'm concerned
and we got to start shaming these
[ __ ] ended believing that
nonsense
that even if you if you're just a whiff
just a [ __ ] whiff of support for
these buffoons is treasonous traitors
you're [ __ ] traitors every last one
of you are traitors to United States
Constitution and the American people
you're not a [ __ ] Patriot you are a
God damn Trader take the flag down [ __ ]
because we find out as well there's
reporting that inside these boxes of
course that's it's not surprising
the [ __ ] that Tish James was looking for
the [ __ ] they subpoenaed
he was hiding that [ __ ] down at
Mar-A-Lago
and now that there's that there's
Federal Criminal
referrals from Dish James
about those [ __ ] documents
those documents are now criminal
evidence for not just this case but
other cases
and these people are going to continue
to support this idiot they think that
this road has some kind of great ending
well folks I'll tell you the ending that
they think it has
they're going to win this midterm
they're going to Crown Him King they're
going to take over our house they're
going to take over our Senate they're
going to get rid of Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris
they're going to take over the United
States and they're going to make it
their little fascist State and they're
going to do whatever the [ __ ] they want
and you're not going to say anything
different because votes don't count here
in America that's what they believe
that's what their plan is you can just
wait till you watch what Ryder Stone
says and Roger Stone is projecting what
Trump is telling him in his [ __ ] ear
believe it that's what is happening
and all these
nincompoop Nazis out there I'm talking
about the foot soldiers
that are still in support of this
[ __ ] idiot and this [ __ ] just vile
nonsense this treasonous [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what it is
it's treason
insurrection rioters
overthrow the game it's [ __ ] treason
I don't know how else to put it
what other [ __ ] word would you use
well where would you use
up and down the board no matter where
you go to no matter which one of these
[ __ ] were involved in planning on
overthrowing our vote and taking away
our democracy full stop 100 they were
all in on treason
the whole lot of them members of
Congress
[ __ ] state legislators
we're just lucky we have a backstop in
this country
we have a backstop of actual democracy
and Justice to some degree
their plan was the and it's obvious in
this video that was four months before
the election their plan was to take
Trump appointed judges and have them
crown him King and if that didn't work
then they would just they would just say
[ __ ] you I'm the president literally
that that is what he says I mean I'm
gonna show it to you
I'm gonna show it to you today of course
I gotta show you this [ __ ] tape
and we're gonna see it tomorrow for the
January 6 Select Committee
I gotta say something about the January
6 select committee and I'm not sure
exactly if it's Benny Thompson or Liz
Cheney here or Jamie Raskin
but I gotta say
they're absolute precision
Razer Precision to absolutely dissect
this entire [ __ ] event
before during the election
the night of the election after the
election the lead up to
the certification of votes after the
certification of votes
the lead up to the January 6th
insurrection
and then even after their Insurrection
failed
is absolutely 100 percent
killing the Republican Party
and the biggest reason why is because
they're still sycophanting for him did
you know did you know that the
Republicans put out some kind of plan no
you didn't no you don't you don't know
anything about it
do you know why because they're drowning
in treason
and we should [ __ ] put our foot on
the back of fascism's head and drown it
in democracy it's enough of the [ __ ]
enough of it
the nonsense the [ __ ] the absolute
[ __ ] lies and the way you can do that
is to pile mountains
mountains of votes on top of these
[ __ ]
can you imagine a world
in less than in less than two months
where the certifications are coming
through and Ron DeSantis is no longer
the governor of Florida Greg Abbott is
no longer the governor of Texas
they lose Senate races all the way down
to my state of Missouri because they're
a bunch of treasonous [ __ ]
and they want to take the rights away
from [ __ ] people
they done they done did it with women in
this country and they're coming for you
and they're coming for your [ __ ]
children
if we pile mountains of votes on these
sons of [ __ ] and show them that
you're not gonna take the [ __ ] Senate
not only you're not going to take the
Senate we're going to take more seats
than you thought
they will be doing really well if Ron
Johnson keeps his seat
as much treason as these [ __ ]
had committed
and been complacent with they know it
and then and then we gain seats in the
house it's up to you to gain these seats
yes I know I know they redistrict in
States and they're trying to cheat I get
it I get it I understand but you cannot
be scared of democracy
you have to lean into it they're trying
to scare you with democracy that's what
they're trying to do they convinced a
whole band of their supporters that
democracy doesn't even exist that way
when they snatch it away from them they
have no [ __ ] clue it was even there
but pro-democracy people understand
that that is not the [ __ ] case that
is a goddamn gaslighting lie
but it's up to you it literally is up to
you to engage in your democracy and yes
you have to use the power of your ballot
to drown fascism with democracy but you
have to engage
just look at what Beto's doing in Texas
engaging
with democracy and people are engaging
back
it's happening folks
now I don't want to get your hopes up
that you don't have to do anything
because that's nonsense too
this democracy [ __ ] is [ __ ] hard it's
difficult
it's not easy the easy thing is to let
an authoritarian tell you what the [ __ ]
to do
you think the women in Iran right now
are having an easy time
gaining back their [ __ ] Liberty their
choice
their religious choice
I don't think all these women who are
taking off their headdresses and burn
them actually want to walk around
without a head they just want the
[ __ ] Liberty
there's something about it there's
something about it
that empowers you
at Liberty that you know you know what
if I change my mind
and I decide I'm not this anymore and
I'm not that anymore I have the liberty
of being who I want to be loving who I
want to love
believing the things that I want to
believe by God you have the [ __ ]
Liberty to be stupid in this country
to believe the nonsense on Fox News you
have that Liberty
the greatest part about Liberty is you
have the Liberty to reject it and say it
loud and proud like I do every [ __ ]
day [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
that's Liberty that's what we strive for
and they're so goddamn deluded that they
don't even think they have Liberty
anymore and Liberty isn't what they
strive for
it's the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is what they think they
they're they're working towards that's
the freedom they want to oppress the
rights of other people and it's not that
[ __ ] many of them folks
it's not that [ __ ] many of them
yeah it feels like it
but you're talking less than 10 percent
but it's up to you to Mound mountains of
votes on top of them because there's
plenty other that are going to be
complacent in their place
so it's up to you it is up to you
to show them who we are
and show the world
you don't think it'll send a signal
to the rest of democracy around the
world when the United States tells Trump
and trumpism to go [ __ ] itself for the
second time
in two years
the first one was 2020. eight million
votes you really think 81 million people
voted for Joe Biden you are crazy
a shitload of people voted against
trumpism
Joe Biden might be a great president
but that ain't the reason why people
voted for him
I would have voted for a goddamn ham
sandwich
to be absolutely Frank with you
I would rather take my [ __ ] Chances
with a ham sandwich than with fascism
and I think the rest of America feels
the same goddamn way we just had to
activate and engage and let the American
people know that hey the threat is still
here it's still here these people who
want to get elected they want to Crown
Donald Trump King the same thing they
wanted in 2020 and we cannot allow them
to have any kind of power inside any
government that we possibly can help
State local
Federal all the way down to the God damn
dog catcher
you want a fascist dog catcher you want
would you want a trump supporter being
your dog catcher
as cruel and is hateful and bigoted are
they are think about how they would
treat an animal
if they treat human beings like they
treat human beings
it's your choice and what a tall boy are
we gonna have plenty of information
tomorrow to make choices hell we got a
lot today that I'm going to
because you can't look away this
ignoring ignoring what these fascists
stay I get that all the time
I wish you'd stop promoting them I wish
you'd stop spreading their [ __ ]
I wish you'd wake up and open your
[ __ ] eyes and start showing it to
your goddamn family to your goddamn
friends
to the people you're around to get them
to engage
scare the ever loving Daylights out of
them you goddamn right you don't think
you don't think there's scary [ __ ] on
the other side of these [ __ ] idiots
getting Reigns of power again when you
watch this Roger Stone video that I'm
going to show you today
the absolute the absolute delusional the
delusional freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is on Full [ __ ]
display
on full [ __ ] display and it has
nothing to do with Liberty
it has everything to do with oppression
it has everything to do with taking your
[ __ ] rights away from you taking your
vote away from you taking your
Constitution taking your democracy
taking away your [ __ ] way of life and
they didn't give a [ __ ] because they
felt like they were entitled to it
because that's what they are they're
entitled little [ __ ]
their Cry Baby ninth kapoot Nazis
and it's treasonous [ __ ]
no matter how you frame it or how the
media wants oh both that [ __ ] there
is no both sides to treason folks there
is no both sides
it's [ __ ] treason
the president of the United States the
administration officials
hell some members of Congress and
members of state legislators who took
Oaths to the Constitution
we're trying to overthrow the
Constitution and our government
and using any means necessary literally
he says any means necessary meaning
violence
no one in this country wants there to be
civil war or violence
and the people who do would get squashed
almost immediately we understand what it
will look like if there would be a Civil
War decent-minded people would
understand that the United States
military would absolutely
destroy anyone who wanted to go against
them
you really think your little stupid pea
shooters no matter how many you have is
going to be some kind of force against
the United States of America
and you want you're so such a patriot
that you want to fight them United
States military oh boy sounds like
you're really for veterans get the [ __ ]
out of here with that nonsense
but I have a feeling folks I have a
really strong feeling because I'm very
confident you know I'm very confident in
democracy because I believe that people
in this country understand what
democracy delivers
I believe that deep down in our core in
our American core
as ridiculous as we are
as is much entitled to delusion as we
want to be as much as we want to ignore
our actual history
and what is real and what is fact deep
down inside of us we know what is most
important to this country
and it is Liberty
it is freedom it is the right
to those Constitutional Powers
that we have as a people
it's our government it's our way of life
it's us we the people
but it's up to you to use it
that power that constitutional power
that is granted to you the government
the people it's only up to you whether
you use it or not
and if you're worried about the voting
laws and them taking your rights away by
suppressing your vote
then you better [ __ ] vote
you better you better crawl over [ __ ]
broken glass and hot coals to get there
that's the way
that's what you have to do
I'm gonna show you a clip of Stacy
Abrams and she's going to explain to you
why Governors are way more important
than who the [ __ ] the president is who
the [ __ ] you remember Congress is
and who the [ __ ] your mayor is
God damn she Sharp
and The Way She lays it out
is absolutely beautiful
she's gonna make a great governor of the
state of Georgia
a great governor
even the people who hate her now will
love her then
I mean they'll pretend
they'll pretend like they hate her
but the thing she'll do for Georgia
for Georgians because she's not just
there for her constituents and it's the
same thing in Texas with Beto
when Texas finally makes the decision
that hey [ __ ] this goddamn Greg Abbott
guy [ __ ] this guy
he's not working for Texas
he's working for him and his donors
when they finally make that decision
even the people who [ __ ] hate battle
right now
even though they're gonna pretend like
they don't they're gonna like the [ __ ]
he does
that's what always happens
you know why because we don't run around
bragging and we should
we don't run around with rhetoric and we
should we don't run around attacking the
other side when we win and we should
they're at our front door trying to take
away our democracy this is not the
Republican party of Ronald Reagan folks
where they're just trying to seize up
power for their for their buddies their
Rich Buddies the one percent
Jesus Christ they're going to take it
away from the one percent too
you don't think the one percent enjoyed
democracy in this country
for them it's a thin veil plutocracy
you don't think they're going to take it
away from them [ __ ]
their goal is to take it away from
everybody just look at what they say
watch this Roger Stone video and tell me
I'm [ __ ] wrong everybody it's Tuesday
and you know what Tuesday means we have
Texas Paul here I believe we're going to
talk about a fugitive in Texas today
there seems to be a famous fugitive
something's going on in Texas down there
someone's running from the law I fought
the law and the law won I wonder if
they're gonna I wonder if
this is this is I can't even believe we
have to talk about this this is [ __ ]
ridiculous
that the head law enforcement officer
basically
in Texas
is a fugitive basically what in the hell
is going on
yeah the greatest part is he's oh he's
Greg Abbotts great buddy they're they're
buddies they're friends and if they're
not we should make them that way that's
right politicize the ever loving [ __ ]
out of this
that's what we should do now Beto's not
but we can do it for him folks we can do
it for him that's the beautiful part
about rhetoric that's the beautiful part
about politization we don't have to
stand around and wait on the politicians
do it we can do it ourselves
yes I know it yeah oh what Tony that's
what the right wing does how do you
think they win you want them to win
which team are you playing on you
playing on team democracy or team
fascist
because if you're not fighting [ __ ]
against them you're fighting with them
when there's
10 people sitting at a table with one
Nazi
there's 11 people
that are Nazis at that table
that's what it is regardless of what end
you're sitting on regardless of of
rather you're talking to them or not or
engaging with them if there's 11 people
at a table and one of those people are
Nazis there's 11 Nazis sitting at that
table
so get with it folks get with it let's
get rid of Greg Abbott let's get rid of
Rhonda Santas because Rhonda Santos can
go [ __ ] himself folks this t-shirt is
flying off the shelves you guys like the
coffee mugs too go to store.beat Tony
michaels.com get the Rhonda santoskin go
[ __ ] himself also get some doubt members
while you're there
but the one that's really hot right now
at
store.dtonymichaels.com is the dark
Brandon exclusive Tony Michael's podcast
Design This thing is hot hot go get them
while they last store that the Tony
michaels.com get your doubt me merch get
your Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ] himself
also support pro-democracy speech
everywhere